[Musique]
le premier dossier du programme feader
2013-2020 géré par le département été
officialisée ce mardi 11 avril dans une
exploitation du tampon jean pierre
hoareau et son fils vont pouvoir
construire une étable de 200 m² pour
l'heure 28 vaches allaitantes un grand
plus pour le confort des bêtes qui en
cas de cyclones ou en hiver dont pour
l'instant aucun abri
mais en fin de compte on va on répond
sur un bâtiment de 28 28 places ce qui
aboutit au point un second troupeau
c'est un deuxième titre à terrasser et
monter la partie maçonnerie la charpente
effet la creuse comme les animaux vous
sur caillebotis et et par un supposé
établi
l'éleveur et son fils se réjouissent de
pouvoir disposer de cette aide
conséquente sur 125 mille euros ils
bénéficieront de 35000 euros de l'europe
et de 12000 euros du département manque
un ou deux de surplus selon serge ouart
conseiller départemental en charge de
l'agriculture étaient présents
l'officialisation de ce dispositif est
pour lui un espoir pour la profession un
message porteur d'espoir aussi pour la
profession agricole de manière générale
et les éleveurs bovins en particulier
puisque c'est un message de dire que les
fonds européens sont libérés qui a
aujourd'hui la possibilité de monter des
dossiers de les déposer au service
instructeur et d'obtenir les
financements je croise et c'est ce
message premier on doit porter en
direction du monde agricole dans son
ensemble
aujourd'hui plus de 1000 dossiers ont
été validés 49 dossiers conventionné
pour 1 7 million d'euros de feder
[Musique]